as we spoke when we were in the break
you just got good news there is a show
an animated movie right now running on
Netflix called Leo starring Adam Sandler
written and directed by this man and
what news did you just get I think it
says that it was the number one uh
something on something great a really
knows how to
promote oh the biggest animated debut
Netflix has ever had is what it says in
the history of that's that's going back
like four years to the creation of NX
but they've had a lot of but they've
debuted a lot of the big blockbuster
movies on there and animated movies this
is uh if you don't know Leo is an
animated movie um co-written by Robert
Smigel co-directed by is it co-directed
or just directed no Co co-directed by
Robert smel with with uh Adam Sandler
Bill Burr many many people and not hoe
Mandel deliberately yeah no no but
that's good pushing so hard for you
right you know and Adam was just like no
way buddy no way I I
just I don't like the guy I don't I I I
I you know I know he's great I know I
know it make the movie huge but I can't
work with him he's so mean anyway I want
to say before the The Reason Not only am
I thrilled to have you here because I'm
a huge fan but Leo I just want to make
sure that people we'll put a link to uh
remind people to watch Leo on Netflix
all Bill Burr and and everybody you did
hire a lot
of strong yeah from Saturday Night Live
yes and Jason Alexander's in it he does
his podcast everyone except you no
that's it really those are the those are
the four big names and you did a lot of
the voices I did a couple of voices in
it yeah yeah you like directing
animation animation is where I it's hard
man but you've done a lot of it it was
funny because when the early reviews
came out there were some critics who
were like it doesn't know what it wants
to be is it for adults or is it for kids
and that was like the whole point that's
the best part of animated movies is you
want the parents to love it too yeah and
it's not like they it's not like it has
inside like pop culture jokes that are
like you know only adults would get it
because they have like a cultural
reference it's more about you're just
laughing at like entitled parents and
substitute teachers and that and just
School politics that kind of thing why
where did you where did you Garner your
school politics well I have kids right
now right who are now they're 15 well I
have an older son with autism as you
know who's 25 but but I have twin boys
that are 15 and when I started writing
this movie uh they were like in fourth
grade and they had already had like two
substitute teachers take over like two
pregnant
teachers are you sure they were pregnant
replaced uh that's a good question and
where if they I think there were some
parents demanding uh that they be tested
to prove it cuz they were so indignant
about getting a substitute I didn't pay
for this teacher what's it's one and a
half teachers right some substitutes are
really good some substitutes we've had
mixed results with substitutes did you
ever substitute no but I was pregnant
and I had maternity leave when I was
teaching and so we had a long-term sub
that was in my classroom and you were
happy with the work that they did well
yeah because I was at a charter school
so they actually hired a long-term sub
that worked at the charter school and it
wasn't a random person right and so that
person had been there for years and we
knew them and stuff so it was all good
this this part is really
boring it's boring no it's relevant to
the movie because so in our movie The
Substitute replaces this really sweet
teacher who's all about positive
reinforcement and the substitute is like
some 75-year-old bitter old lady who's
just you know pulling out like um you
know demerit things and uh and brass
knuckles and and she's just uh totally
old school and and hilariously mean and
and
useless